the country is in crisis it has been in
crisis
for more than a year the state is near
nearly bankrupt
and it's just a daily struggle for every
lebanese we're outside
one of the gas stations here and you see
the long
lines people wait for hours just to fill
up one third
of their fuel tank there is a fuel
crisis
just as there is a lack of medicine
after people fill up their cars with gas
they go to pharmacies to start looking
for medicines which more often than not
they do not find
and then there's hyperinflation the
price of food
it has more than tripled in recent
months
yet the minimum wage remains the same
and the majority of the lebanese people
earn in
the local currency which is now worth
less than 50
dollars and the reason is if anymore
we're dying they are destroying us we
are destroying us
we have money we cannot buy anything we
have money
really we have money but we cannot buy
anything that's not life
it's a hell there are those there are
those people who still earn a salary
but unemployment is on the rise it's now
35 percent
and research institutes say it is going
to increase uh to 40 percent
the this is a country which is starving
for dollars
for hard currency and the central bank's
mandatory reserves is drying out and the
central bank was giving importers
dollars in order to you know buy fuel uh
medicine at an affordable price to
subsidize these goods
and like i mentioned it's running out
fuel prices have increased by
by 50 by 50 percent so has
the price of bread so people are
struggling
those and you just heard that man there
those who have money and who are able
to buy something just can't because they
cannot find it in a country which
imports
almost everything that it needs